-As we've seen repeatedly
over the last few months,
when the Trump administration
is confronted with facts
that don't support their agenda,
they try to discredit
the sources of those facts,
and right now,
they're using that same strategy
on healthcare.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Of course, since basically
the beginning of his campaign,
Trump has tried to undermine
the press
as the source of information.
In fact, even when he's making
small talk with world leaders,
he can't help but make sarcastic
comments about the media.
On Tuesday, he held a photo op
in the Oval Office
with the crown prince
of Saudi Arabia,
and it was super awkward.
[ Camera shutters clicking ]
-They're very nice people.
-We hope so.
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Audience laughs ]
-Are you guys
in the White House,
or on a terrible first date?
[ Audience laughs ]
-[ As Trump ] Do you always
wear that thing on your head?
-[ As bin Salman ] I do.
Do you always wear that thing
on your head?"
[ Audience laughs ]
[ Normal voice ] Of course...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Of course,
Trump dislikes the media
because they often report
basic facts
that challenge his world view
for the same reason
his administration now dislikes
the Congressional Budget Office,
which released a damning report
on the Republican
healthcare plan on Monday
that projected the bill
would cause
a stunning 24 million Americans
to lose coverage.
Now, that might seem like
a disaster,
but House Speaker Paul Ryan
actually tried to spin it
as a positive,
prompting skepticism
even from straight-laced
Fox News anchor Bret Baier.
-If you read this entire report,
I'm pretty encouraged by it.
I'm excited about this analysis.
And I'm really, actually,
frankly encouraged.
-Mr. Speaker, if you're
encouraged by this CBO report,
what's a CBO report
you're discouraged by?
[ Audience laughs ]
That's the closest Bret Baier
has ever come to saying,
"Bye, Felicia."
[ Audience laughs ]
Also, Paul Ryan,
you're encouraged
that 24 million people
will be thrown off
their insurance?
Is that really the word
you want to use,
or are you thinking
of a different E-word?
-Excellent.
-There it is.
[ Audience laughs ]
So how can Paul Ryan say
he's encouraged by this report?
Well, he makes several
misleading claims.
For example, Ryan says
the report confirms
that the bill
will lower premiums,
which is technically true, but
only for young, healthy people.
Older people would see
their premiums skyrocket.
In fact, the CBO report finds
that the average 64-year-old
earning $26,500 would see
their premiums go up from $1,700
to $14,600 a year.
So get ready to start
running into your grandpa
working at Subway.
-[ As old man ]
When I was a kid,
12-inch Italians weren't even
allowed in the country!
[ Audience laughs ]
[ Normal voice ] So, Paul Ryan
has chosen the strategy
of trying to make the CBO report
sound positive,
and what about Trump
and his surrogates?
They're just saying we shouldn't
believe the CBO at all --
Like CNN commentator and Trump
supporter Jeffrey Lord,
who tried to discredit
the CBO report
by making an analogy
that didn't quite hold up.
-We don't know what
the weather's gonna be.
It's gonna snow, but how much?
I mean, we don't know.
We don't trust weathermen,
you know,
so why should we trust the CBO?
All right, first of all,
the reason we don't trust
weathermen is because
they have names like
Dallas Rains or Storm Tornado.
[ Audience laughs ]
And second of all,
in this analogy,
if the CBO is the weatherman,
then that makes Donald Trump
this kid.
-Dewpoints in the 20s
and near 30 degrees
across central Mississippi.
Well, hey there.
-I don't know what's going on,
but Zayn doesn't know.
Are you sure?
Are you crazy sure?!
-[ Chuckles nervously ] Well...
-Ca-caw! Ca-caw!
-We've got a little bit
of interesting things
going on right now.
-Ffft! Pbht!
-Take a look at what's
going on right now.
You want to point out
the weather right now?
-Yeah, there are farts
everywhere and toots!
I don't even know! It's crazy!
[ Audience laughs, applause ]
-You can laugh...
You can laugh, but Donald Trump
just made that kid
Secretary of Weather.
[ Audience laughs ]
And then yesterday,
White House Spokesman/Hostage,
Sean Spicer, also tried
to discredit the CBO report.
Spicer tried to claim
that the new GOP bill
was only the first part of
a three-part healthcare plan,
meaning the CBO's report
was inaccurate
because it didn't
take into account
future legislation
that doesn't exist yet.
And he kept using one word
in particular.
-The comprehensive nature
of the three-pronged plan...
In prongs two and three...
Doing the first prong of this...
On the first prong alone...
Prong one of three prongs...
But the second prong of this...
So, prong two is actually
fairly easy to do.
The third prong...
This piece of this prong only...
Without looking
at prong two and three...
-Wait, is "prong"
Sean Spicer's safe word,
and he forgot to tell everyone?
[ Audience laughs ]
Prong! You guys, prong!
I'm gonna go back to
the Oval Office, but prong!
[ Audience laughs ]
Of course, as usual, Trump
is doing a complete 180 here,
because he used to love
the Congressional Budget Office
when it suited his needs,
tweeting about the CBO at least
13 times to criticize Obama.
The only constant in all of this
is that Trump likes something
if it agrees with him
and he hates it if it doesn't.
Take for example
the monthly jobs report.
Trump famously used to call
the unemployment rate "phony,"
but now that he's president,
he's bragging about
the jobs numbers.
So how does the White House
explain the flip flop?
Sean Spicer had this to say
last week.
-I talked to the president
prior to this,
and he said to quote him
very clearly.
They may have been phony in the
past, but it's very real now.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
[ Audience laughs ]
We're so pronged.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Even when Trump makes a claim
in his own words,
like when he accused
President Obama
of wiretapping him,
we can't be sure
if we're supposed to actually
take him literally.
Remember, Trump tweeted,
"Terrible!
Just found out that Obama had my
'wires tapped' in Trump Tower."
And "President Obama was tapping
my phones in October."
And, yet, when Spicer was asked
if Trump had any proof
that Trump was indeed
wiretapped,
Spicer responded with this.
-He doesn't really think
that President Obama
went up and tapped his phone
personally.
The president
"used the word wiretapped"
in quotes to mean, broadly,
surveillance
and other activities.
-Because what is "wiretap"
if not a cool slang term
that means a bunch
of different things like,
"We should wiretap some molly"
or "I want to wiretap dat ass."
[ Audience laughs ]
Now, today, the Attorney General
Jeff Sessions,
who would know if there was
any evidence of wiretapping,
was asked if he had provided any
such evidence to the president,
and he seemed flustered.
-Um...
Look, um...
The answer is no.
Um, but, um...
-[ As Sessions ] Well,
you better get that man
some sweet tea
and a porch to sit on,
because he is sweating more
than a gator in a boot store!
[ Audience laughs ]
[ Normal voice ] So,
Trump's own attorney general
couldn't give us any evidence,
then there was the Republican
overseeing the investigation
in the House, Devin Nunes,
who offered a similar argument
to Spicer,
claiming Obama didn't personally
go to Trump Tower
and put in a wiretap.
-We don't have any evidence that
that took place.
I don't think there was
an actual tap of Trump Tower.
President Obama
wouldn't physically go over
and wiretap Trump Tower,
so now you have to decide,
as I mentioned to you last week,
are you gonna take the tweets
literally, and if you are,
then clearly the President
was wrong.
-Stop telling us Obama didn't
physically go to Trump Tower!
Nobody thought that!
[ Audience laughing ]
[ As Obama ] Uh, hello!
I'm here...
I'm, uh, here from
A.T. and, uh...T.
[ Audience laughs ]
[ Normal voice ]
So, sometimes Trump is pro-CBO,
other times he's anti-CBO,
sometimes he says
the jobs numbers are phony,
other times says they're real,
sometimes he says things
in quotes,
other times
he really means them,
but one thing we do know
is we can't believe his promises
on healthcare,
like when he promised
during the campaign
that he wouldn't let people
suffer as president,
using one favorite phrase
over and over again.
-I said,
"Nobody's going to be dying
on the street if I'm president.
-Did you say you're a liberal
on healthcare?
-I will not let people die on
the streets if I'm president.
People are not gonna
die in the middle of the street.
die on the sidewalk.
You're not gonna let people die
sitting in the middle
of a street.
-Why does he think people
are walking out
to the middle of the street
to die?
Must...make it to street!
[ Audience laughing ]
Sit down in middle of street!
And die with dignity!
So, Trump made huge promises
on healthcare
that he clearly had no intention
of keeping.
His bill would cut Medicare
and kick millions off insurance.
If it passes, we're all
gonna need a safe word.
-Prong. Prong. Prong. Prong.
Prong. Prong. Prong.
-[ To the tune of "Thong Song" ]
♪ Prong, p-prong, prong, prong ♪
[ Audience laughs ]
That's been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]